وبالتزامن مع الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه
تصاعدت حده التوترات في منطقه باب المندب
اثر العمليات التي شنها الحوثيون على
السفن المرتبطه باسرائيل واعلان التحالف
تقو الولايات المتحده في منطقه البحر
الاحمر ينضم الينا من الخارجيه الامريكيه
المبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى اليمن تيموثي
ليندر كينج سيد سيد تيموثي يعني قبل
وصولكم الى المنطقه تتصاعد التوترات في
العراق والبحر الاحمر يعني ما الذي
تحملونه في جعبت في زيارتكم
هذه شكرا جزيلا اعتقد ان الرساله الاكثر
اهميه التي تحاول ان توصلها الولايات
المتحده للمنطقه والتي ارسلها وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي الذي هو في تركيا الان
رساله هي رساله خفض التصعيد كيف بامكاننا
ان نخفض التوتر المنتشر في مناطق مختلفه
من
هذه الجانب من العالم بما في ذلك في غزه
وفي مناطق اخرى اذا سيكون هناك مساعدات
متزايده يتم ارسالها الى غزه وننظر الى
السبل التي من خلالها بامكان المجتمع
الدولي ان يوصل مساعداته الى غزه هذه
تعتبر من المباد الاسيه التي سيناقشها
بلكن في زيارته هاته سيد تيموثي لندر كينج
انشات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع
مجموعه من الدول تحالف يدعى حارس الازدهار
كيف الا ان هجمات الحوثيين في البحر
الاحمر لم تتوقف هل س يؤدي ذلك الى تغيير
رؤيه الولايات المتحده وتعاطيها مع
الحوثيين
بدايه
اعتقد ان القضيه الاساسيه هنا هو ان
عمليات الهجوم التي تجري على السفن منذ
اكتوبر الماضي تشكل تهديدا للتجاره
العالميه وللمجتمع الدولي لذلك هناك
الكثير من الدول التي وقعت على الانضمام
لهذا التحالف في اطار البيان الذي يتحدث
عن نفسه وهو يتعلق بتحالف حارس الازدهار
وهو قوه بحريه متعدده الجنسيات حيث انه
يتم استهداف سفن مختلفه التي هي مرتبطه
بالكثير من الدول وليس فقط باسرائيل
لذلك وزير الخارجيه وانا كذلك ساسافر الى
المنطقه كلنا سنحاول ان يكون هناك عمليه
خفض للتصعيد في منطقه البحر الاحمر وننظر
الى الاولويات الا وهي الامن والسلام
والاستقرار في اليمن وكيفيه تحقيق ذلك
كمجتمع دولي ك ولايات متحده امريكيه فان
اهدافنا هي تتعلق بخفض التصعيد وكذلك سحب
القوات هذه العمليات التي تجري لسنتين في
اليمن كل هذه الامور قوضت بسبب عمليات
الهجوم على السفن وبالتالي نحن نرمي الى
خفض التصعيد مع القوات المختلفه والدول
المختلفه هذا هو هدفنا طيب هناك ضغوط على
واشنطن حتى من قبل حلفائها لتغيير تعاطيها
مع جماعه
انصار الحوثيين ما قولكم في ذلك ما
تعليقكم على ضوء ما يجري في البحر الاحمر
بالطبع اعتقد ان هناك خيار امام انصار
الله امام الحوثيين هذا الخيار هو ان هل
يريدون ان يكونوا طرفا يعمل من اجل السلام
في بلدهم ام انهم يريدون ان يتخذوا قرارات
هذه القرارات التي ستؤدي الى المزيد
والمزيد من الاعداء لانصار الله من مناطق
مختلفه من العالم هذه الدول التي تاثرت
سلبا نتيجه لعمليات الهجوم هي نفس الدول
التي تحتاجها انصار الله وتحتاجها اليمن
من اجل ارساء الاستقرار ومن اجل تعزيز هذه
الجهود جهود السلام التي هي ضروريه
بالنسبه للشعب اليمني بالنسبه لنزع وخفض
التصعيد وكذلك الاستقرار في مطار صنعاء
وان يكون هناك قدره على التحرك داخل
البلاد بحريه كلها كلها تواجه صعوبات بسبب
استهداف السفن وبالتالي بالنسبه لاي دعم
قد يحضون به بالنسبه لتحقيق جهود السلام
هذا يقتضي العمل على هذا الجانب امل ان
بلينكن واخرين في المنطقه امل ان يعملوا
على خفض الذي يعتبر اساسيا من اجل تعزيز
جهود السلام في اليمن طيب دول كفرنسا لم
تنضم لتحالف حارس الازدهار هل ثمت خلافات
بين الولايات المتحده وحلفائها على
مقاربتها لهذا التحالف
واهدافه لا اعتقد ان هناك اي خلافات او
اعتراضات لان كل هذه الدول بما في ذلك
الولايات المتحده فرنسا وحتى الصين كلنا
جميعنا ندعم حريه الملاحه في البحر الاحمر
وفي كل الممرات المائيه المختلفه عمليات
الهجوم المتهوره التي تجري في هذه المنطقه
ضد السفن لابد ان يتم العمل عليها واذا ما
كان هناك مشاكل طبعا وعوائق ل دخول
المساعدات الى غزه هذا يرفع من الكلفه
وهذا لا يساعد الشعب الغزي باي حال من
الاحوال ومن خلال فهمي فان من خلال ما
اعتقد كذلك فان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
سيحاول ان يرفع العوائق التي تعيق دخول
مساعدات الانسانيه الى غزه من اجل تحسين
حياه الغزيين هذه من المبادئ الاساسيه
وبالتالي نحن نعمل على هذا الاساس من اجل
خفض ور وليس التصعيد طيب كيف يمكن ان يتم
ذلك هنالك حديث عن خطط تعدها واشنطن
لمهاجمه الحوثيين او لشن هجمات محتمله على
الحوثييين ما هي النقطه التي يمكن ان تلجا
اليها عندها الولايات المتحده لمثل هكذا
خيار ش ان عمليات الهجوم من قبل الحوثيين
على السفن ادت الى حاله من الظر في الكثير
من العواصم في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
الحوثيون قاموا باحتجاز سفينه وحولوا كذلك
ازاله او العمل على كذلك عمليات اخرى وهذا
ادى الى خساره الارواح وهذا شيء ناسف له
ومن جانب اخر ليس هناك اي تسامح تجاه هذا
السلوك متهور في بعض الحالات كان لدينا
بعض القلق بشان بعض عمليات الهجوم التي
تستهدف اصولا وسفنا امريكيه هذه الامور
ليس بامكان الولايات المتحده ان تقبلها
وان تشاهدها هكذا دون م رده فعل وبالتالي
اعتقد ان المسار الحكيم بالنسبه للحوثيين
هو الابتعاد عن عمليات الهجوم على السفن
في البحر الاحمر والتركيز على احتياجات
الشعب يمني والتي تريدها ويريدها المجتمع
الدولي الذي يقوده الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ليكون هناك نهايه للنزاع الذي
يجري في اليمن شكرا لك المبعوث الامريكي
الخاص الى اليمن تيموثي ليندر كين كنت
معنا من الخارجيه
الامريكيه